weekly basis to pick up groceries
choosing from food that has been
discarded by supermarkets hotels and
restaurants the food bank collects these
leftovers and distributes them to people
of limited means Mike lagina Schaeffler
her pension is meager often inadequate
to cover costs at the supermarket but
here she's able to get what she needs
one head of broccoli potatoes onions a
kohlrabi and sometimes maybe cabbage if
you ask but it's enough it's really
quite generous anyone who can prove that
he or she is a need is allowed to pick
up groceries at one of Germany's 900
food banks in lagina Schieffelin case
her pension is simply too low she puts
off needed purchases and depends on
social services or even hopes for a
lottery win I really need a new stove so
I just have to see if management will
let me have one otherwise I have to save
up until I can afford one today German
charities presented a new report warning
that poverty in the country remains at a
high level despite a robust economy and
that means more and more pensioners like
lagina Schaeffler are affected we must
assume that the numbers of pensioners
living in poverty will drastically
increase over the next 10 years we will
be overwhelmed by an avalanche of old
age poverty if no political action is
taken they're calling for politicians to
increase support payments to welfare
recipients as well as to raise the level
of pensions the kina shephelah has seen
it with her own eyes more and more
people in similar circumstances are
regularly visiting the food bank because
their income is simply too little